life is beautiful bringing some of the
biggest names in music who will be
playing for the festival for the very
first time we sat down with electronic
music producer and artist rehab
something you'll see first on las vegas
now
it's really nice to uh you know to play
something uh that you've never played
before it's a new feeling a new
experience because i've done a lot of
things already so
i i'm super excited i'm playing the very
first time i always saw this uh you know
the flyer always like wow with a nice
lighten up you know because you're
surrounded by a lot of talent and you
know that
makes you realize that
you know like wow maybe i have some
talent i just looked at the flyer no
arctic monkeys they're performing after
me i'm gonna go and check them out
[Applause]
with a strictly dance festival you kind
of know what to expect here there's a
little bit more surprise you know also
because there's like a change of slots
there's like
you're up against the pop rock band so
like you have to keep the people there
you have to you know i would say you
have to work a little bit harder but
also it's very interesting you know
because it motivates you to try also
different things and also to prepare
very properly that you can go all sides
of the spectrum hope i come back for you
to see that's the goal uh pasqual what's
up
i think edc or something else but at the
moment just life is beautiful focus on
that and then on to the next